it's officially week three of the google
cloud next on air
which means we're focusing on
infrastructure
i'm priyanka vergaria and welcome to
this week in cloud
where we're taking a sneak peek at this
week's content
week three is all about infrastructure
meaning we want to help you
migrate and modernize so we've got tons
of informational sessions from virtual
machines
to networking and looking at the details
of cloud environment
this week is also full of customer
migration stories so you can hear the
decisions that drove
companies to the cloud and how they
planned out their migration strategy
let's shine the spotlight on proactive
network operations a session that shows
off
how the network intelligence center can
help you monitor
troubleshoot and even visualize your
network this session is pretty cool
because whether you're about to migrate
to cloud
or you've been there for years network
outages are always concerning
so learning to be proactive with your
network operations is a skill that will
always be valuable
fun fact i'm kind of a cloud nerd which
is why my playlist has
alerting best practices this session
will be a thorough explanation of the
alerts feature in google cloud
monitoring and the many ways you can
tweak your alerts to find meaningful
signals in your data
from aggregation to filtering and
grouping and even to aligners there's
plenty to learn and i can't wait to wrap
things
up check out the weekly recap with brian
dorsey who will also be hosting a q a
session
it's a great chance to hear some of the
answers to questions like which cloud
offering
you should use in which scenario and
what you should think about when looking
at an enterprise migration
with all of the sessions this week you
can feel ready to manage your cloud
environment
to add these sessions to your digital
playlist check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
below or tweet
us using the hashtag googlecloudnext
we'll see you in the cloud
you